[Music]
three years ago I went on my first date
with Brian we had matched on a dating
app and started texting right away he
was so enthusiastic and compassionate he
would text me hey with an exclamation
point followed by how's it going we
really hit it off he was just so easy to
talk to
fast forward to our first date it was
awful
we couldn't keep a conversation going
his voice was monotone he failed to make
eye contact and he wasn't even asking
questions so much for enthusiastic and
compassionate frustrations set in as I
counted down the minutes until freedom
this situation is a prime example of
what I call fictionalizing reality my
conversations with Brian were real but
they were just text on a screen
no body language no vocal cues I was
working with an incomplete picture so to
compensate I colored in what was missing
with bright shades of exuberance and
charm
I had fictionalized my reality
technology had brought me to Brian but
it also introduced ambiguity which
ultimately led to my disappointment we
are more digitally connected than ever
before exchanging on average 250 text
messages and emails every day but only
so much can be said with a digital
message which leads to a number of
challenges in his research on human
communication professor Albert Mehrabian
hints toward some of these challenges
and why technology may interfere with
three critical elements of our
conversation our clarity our intention
and our vulnerability he explains that
our nonverbal cues specifically our tone
of voice and body language help change
the attitudes and feelings of others
more so than the actual words we say let
me give you an example I could say I
can't wait
or I can't wait my tone of voice and
body language help to communicate my
excitement and enthusiasm or lack
thereof he further explains that 93% of
our impact is attributable to these
nonverbal cues where's our actual
content contributes to just 7% this
concept also applies to text messaging
and email our message communicates 7% of
our message but leaving us in the 93
percent darkness where it's hard to
detect clarity intention and
vulnerability as recipients we are often
left feeling confused or doubtful as
senders anxious and misunderstood both
sides are left feeling disconnected but
why first technology compromises clarity
last week I had to cancel plans with my
friend I sent him a quick text
explaining the situation expecting
disappointment a few hours later my
phone buzzed his response it's okay , I
understand
period it's okay I understand
he was definitely mad it's okay I
understand
Oh totally fine but which was it he
hadn't used an emoji or an exclamation
point he must be mad
this conversation had me doubting the
status of our friendship I was
embarrassed by my flakiness I was afraid
to reach out it was unclear what he was
saying I decided I maybe overthinking
everything
so I decided to give him a call sure
enough he did understand and we
rescheduled our dinner for another night
I had fictionalized the 93% of his
message he had only given me 7% and
unfortunately for us as psychology
research shows when we're given
ambiguity we tend to assume the worst
I'm sure as you have experienced even
the smallest language or punctuation
choice can lead to hours days or even
weeks of frustration and resentment
secondly technology compromises
intention prior to starting my MBA
program at Stanford I was a young
business professional on Wall Street
making powerpoints and consuming
caffeine like my job depended on it to
be clear my job did depend on it I had
worked tirelessly on an extensive pitch
deck I was on version 16 when I sent the
document to my boss for a final review
the next morning and email sat at the
top of my Inbox
I took a deep breath and clicked into
the email Thanks
period what are you kidding me did I
make a mistake does he know how long I
spent working on this project there is
no way I'm spending this much time on
the next one n Oh W a Y period this
email from my boss left me feeling
unappreciated and unsupported this this
interaction wasn't uncommon with him but
this last message left me feeling
completely demoralized to the point that
I considered looking for a new role that
is until I ran into my boss and he
congratulated me on a job well done
wait what to my surprise he had been so
incredibly impressed with the pitch deck
that he printed the deck as is replied
with a quick thx and moved on failing to
see the intention behind his thanks I
had fictionalized my reality yet again
when it comes to email and text we are
often overconfident in our ability to
convey our complete thoughts and
feelings assuming that the recipient
shares the same context that we do this
can lead to problems
reducing self-confidence and morale over
time which can deteriorate your
important relationships
lastly technology compromises
vulnerability my phone buzzed as I
received one text message just two words
my body fell within my seat
my dad had informed me that my only
grandfather had passed away but his
message felt abrupt harsh emotionless
what I saw in this moment was support
and strength from my dad but instead I
felt disconnected I was afraid to delve
into the 93% darkness
I couldn't fictionalize this reality
I fail to detect my father's true
feelings and I struggled to expose my
own vulnerability to him again I have
been provided a snippet of content but
the rest was ambiguous it's hard to
choose the right words for a text or
email making it hard to express our true
feelings in important moments like this
one technology allows us to accomplish
incredible things but by virtue of its
digital form it can get in the way of
truth and genuine connection so if you
seek to build meaningful connection how
exactly do you do that strive for
clarity instead of it's okay I
understand try it's okay thanks for
letting me know I'd love to catch up
let's reschedule a clear tone goes a
long way
express your intention explicitly
instead of replying with thanks you
could try this is great I appreciate
your hard work Thanks
with just eight additional words my boss
could have adequately expressed his
appreciation giving me confidence in my
work convey more emotion even when
difficult your grandfather has passed
away I know this is hard for all of us
but stay strong call me when you can I
love you Digital messaging is a powerful
tool and if you use it with intention
you can wield powerful results you can
prevent others from fictionalizing their
reality instead of creating unnecessary
frustration or distance you can build
self-confidence and morale join me in
tackling the dark side of digital
communication so we can build better
relationships
[Applause]
[Music]